في الوقت الذي تشتد فيه الحرب الروسيه
تشهد حكومتك اضطرابات مزلزله اقالات
واستقالات بسبب قضايا فساد ابرز القيادات
التي تمت اقالتهام رئيس مكتب الرئيس
الاكراني كريمه الذي كان مسؤولا عن مشاريع
اعاده الاعمار كما استقال نائب وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني بعد فضيحه فساد فتصلاف
كان مسؤولا عن الخدمات اللوجستيه للجيش
كذلك تمت اقاله نائب المدعي العام
الاوكراني علي
خلفيه فضيحه رحلته باهظه الثمن الى
اسبانيا للاستجمام اثناء الحرب
الذي تمت اقالته من منصب نائب لوزير تنميه
المجتمعات والاقاليم والبنيه التحتيه فقد
احتجزه المكتب الوطني لمكافحه الفساد بسبب
اختلاس اموالهم من الميزانيه ويشطبه في
حصوله على رشوه كما اعلن وزير مجلس
الوزراء
عن اقاله حكام العسكريين لخمس مناطق
اوكرانيه ت ومعارك ضاريه مع روسيا حاليا
ومن غير الواضح حتى الان اسباب العقاله